archeologists in Egypt are celebrating a
newly unearthed tomb as a one-of-a-kind
fine
the hidden resting place for an Egyptian
royal priest has been untouched for
about 44 hundred years it's covered with
exceptionally well-preserved statues and
hieroglyphics the discovery was made
last Thursday in the Saqqara pyramid
complex just south of Cairo Jonathan
Vigliotti shows us how it's the latest
in a series of big finds in Egypt this
year it's an ancient treasure chest
spread out over two levels a tomb so
perfectly preserved it's been called the
most significant discovery in decades
more than two dozen statues guard the
chamber and drawings of a family are
spread throughout like an Egyptian photo
album the walls covered in carvings
depicting some of their favorite
activities hunting musical performances
and even sailing their modern-day
outings setting stone and vibrantly
painted more than 4,400 years ago the
discovery of today it's one of the most
important one for me because number one
it's almost intact tomb number two it's
all Kingdom dr. Mustapha Wazir his team
believed the tomb was the final resting
place of a royal priest named wat egg
who apparently really loved his mother
more than one dozen discoveries have
been made in Egypt this year including a
sarcophagus in Luxor an ancient
necropolis and a tomb of a high
priestess these ancient secrets good for
both history and Egypt's struggling
tourism industry archeologists are now
hopeful they'll find Wat a sarcophagus
believed to be still hidden within the
tool for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti London mummy with
mommy issues there will be